[Musique]
la production plastic s'accélère encore
dans le monde et le recyclage est
largement insuffisant pour éviter la
pollution 9 milliard deux cents millions
de tonnes de matières plastiques ont été
produites dans le monde depuis 70 ans et
seulement 10% de tous plastique a été
recyclé depuis selon l'atlas du
plastique un portrait publié par des
chercheurs allemands en fait 40% que les
produits sont jetés après à peine un
mois
les emballages en particulier ceux à
usage unique représente plus du tiers du
plastique produits dans le monde
viennent ensuite les plastiques utilisés
dans les secteurs de la construction du
textile et des biens de consommation
les chercheurs soulignent qu'il faudra
faire bien plus que de bannir les sacs
en épicerie pour s'attaquer réellement
aux problèmes
[Musique]